The Joe Rogan Experience I think they
are doing and by they I mean Dr Evil
well no it's bigger than that it's
bigger than that by they I mean uh the
the Democrat Elite that have vast
control it's not just the President
Biden or the Biden Administration it's
the media it's the politicized
Department of Justice they are doing
that the timing of
all of these charges against Trump is
Not an Accident the the fact that they
want to hold multiple uh Court hearings
for these charges the day the day before
super Tuesday
which is a major turning point in any
candidates election they want to kick
off these uh uh Court hearings
the day before super Tuesday it's not an
accident this is all happening uh right
now it's Banana Republic stuff it it
really is and that's what they're doing
is again these
these terrible things that are happening
in our country are happening because we
have people in power who care more about
themselves and their power than they do
about the people this country our
constitution our democracy they are
setting this incredibly dangerous
precedent
that now much like many banana republics
in the world whoever's in power has the
ability to politicize and weaponize that
power to go after their political
opponent
that's that's the real take away
whatever people think about Trump or
whatever the consequences and
implications of what what is actually
happening and what so many of the
Democrat Elite are justifying in the
name of protecting democracy is actually
destroying it and when you look at the
charges like when he gets indicted where
the day before there's a scandal it's
there's a chart of the the revelations
yeah and then day after Trump gets
arraigned
it's crazy yeah it's crazy
it's just the whole thing is just so so
how much do we take I mean what what do
we do what can be done what can be done
you know I mean I don't know at this
point well I mean it does it starts with
us
it starts with us as Americans taking
our own responsibility seriously
um you know in the in the Constitution
Bill of Rights it talks about
our government exists with the consent
of the governed yeah
that's us
but these guys yeah yeah but then when
you have things like the Deep State like
they're they're oh there's no question
there's no question the the the the
these powerful entities are very real
and they they want nothing more than to
hold on to their power but isn't it
fascinating that that was not generally
discussed before 2016.
before Trump got into office that was
not like a big concern that people had
like the CIA because he's the guy who
broke through right right he's the I
mean you know you look at what the FBI
and what the government was doing uh
during before that election even
happened to try to take him off the
field to try to eliminate him from being
a choice that voters could seriously
consider look at what the mainstream
even Fox News did at that time to try to
make it so people didn't take him
seriously he's the guy that broke
through and so what did they do every
single day of his presidency and now for
years Beyond they're continuing to try
to make sure uh that he is not allowed
to carry out you know the things that he
was talking about and he is the guy
who's as you've talked about he's the
guy who talked very openly about the
military industrial complex yeah and
their power and the Deep State and these
entities